[Musique]
bonjour à toutes bonjour à tous je suis
ravie de vous retrouver pour un nouveau
numéro div livre aujourd'hui je suis en
compagnie de Philippe goû bonjour
bonjour Mathilde alors vous êtes auteur
photographe et amoureux de la ville de
Saint-Germain en Laé tellement amoureux
que vous en avez écrit un livre pourquoi
alors en fait je connais Saint-Germain
depuis très longtemps et j'habitais à
Orgeval à côté de Saint-Germain et quand
nous sommes venus habiter à
Saint-Germain euh il y a un gritur qui
nous a fait visiter la ville un quoi un
gritur c'est quoi un gritteur ah les
gritteur c'est une association qui s'est
créée aux États-Unis au moment de
l'attentat sur les tours h HM et qui
avait pour but de faire visiter la ville
de New York euh fait vu par les
habitants c'est-à-dire pas vu comme un
guide mais vu par des gens qui aiment
leur ville et cette association s'est
développé partout dans le monde et il y
a une antenne maintenant ici à
Saint-Germain et donc un petit groupe de
tris quatre personnes qui font visiter
la ville pas comme des guides mais comme
des amoureux de la ville et donc c'est
eux qui vous ont donné cette fibre cet
amour de Saint-Germain en lait en fait
oui en fait c'était un peu comme au
rugby quand on marque un essai euh ce
jour-là vraiment j'ai eu envie de le
faire et puis quand j'ai expliqué à au
gritor que je faisais beaucoup de photos
et que j'écrivais elle m'a dit oh là là
il y a certainement un livre à faire
donc votre livre fait environ une
centaine de pages et sa particularité
c'est qu'il est connecté il y a des QR
Codes VO oui alors en fait l'idée c'est
sur chaque page c'est de présenter un
sujet de la ville et puis avec un pitch
un petit un petit message très court qui
donne envie d'aller voir le l'endroit
que l'on connaît bien ou un endroit
insolide de la ville et puis pour ceux
qui veulent avoir des informations
complémentaires il y a un QR code qui
permet d'avoir accès à une base de
données qui donne plein d'informations
sur le lieu qui est visité et puis
l'avantage aussi c'est que les
commentaires peuvent être ajoutés au
peuvent être ajoutés dans le temps donc
les lecteurs peuvent laisser des
commentaires c'est les lecteurs peuvent
laisser des commentaires il ils peuvent
laisser des photos ils peuvent laisser
des vieilles cartes postales et puis ça
vient enrichir le livre c'est quoi
l'objectif de créer une communauté
autour de la ville de saintgerl j'aime
bien votre formule il y a vraiment une
communauté et en fait c'est ce que j'ai
ressenti quand j'ai fait le tour de tout
ce qui a visité à à Saint-Germain j'ai
senti qu'il y avait vraiment une
communauté entre les habitants c'est
génial alors en introduction de votre
livre vous avez demandé à chat JPT là
l'intelligence artificielle si Louis XIV
aimerit VI aimerait vivre à
Saint-Germain en lait il vous a répondu
une réponse un peu positive ouais et là
bon en CH GPT ça c'est des réponses
standardisées et cetera mais j'ai trouvé
que la la réponse était intéressante
parce que d'une part euh le le logiciel
a dit que la ville avait beaucoup évolué
depuis loui XIV ce qui paraî être être
évident mais en respectant l'historique
de la ville et c'est ça qui est qui est
génial dans le livre j'ai voulu montrer
qu'il y avait un lien entre le passé et
le présent et partout il y a ce lien
entre ce qu'a vécu Louis XIV et puis ce
que l'on vit aujourd'hui alors justement
votre livre il est découpé en plusieurs
thématiques vous avez fait une
thématique sur l'histoire le patrimoine
de Saint-Germain ené il y a aussi une
grande partie sur la forêt de
Saint-Germain ouii c'est important pour
moi oui est-ce que vous pouvez voilà
nous décrire un petit peu ce qu'il y a
dans ces différentes pages alors sur le
le le le patrimoine on a eu une occasion
assez extraordinaire parce que euh on
vient d'inaugurer le grand bassin euh en
face du château de de de de
Saint-Germain et euh euh euh j'ai voulu
euh euh montrer dans le livre une photo
inédite dans laquelle on voit à la fois
toute la ville dans le fond le grand
bassin d'un côté et le château de
l'autre et donc tout le livre est fait
avec des photos originales euh même des
choses qui paraissent classique du du
château et bien tout est photographié
avec un angle de vue nouveau voilà c'est
vous qui avez fait ces photos alors moi
j'ai fait beaucoup de photos j'été aidé
par quelqu'un qui s'appelle Jacques Pary
qui était le photographe de la ville
pendant une bonne dizaine d'années donc
c'était vraiment intéressant on a
beaucoup échangé tous les deux moi j'ai
échangé avec mon club de Photo
International aussi pour discuter de la
qualité des photos que je je faisais
donc ça c'est sur le le côté historique
h euh et puis je fais partie de
l'association des amis de la forêt de de
Saint-Germain et de Marly et je pense
que à Saint-Germain la forêt c'est
quelque chose qui est essentiel c'est le
poumon ver de la ville mais c'est aussi
euh plein de choses historiques des
oratoires des des des colonnes des
statues c'est vraiment intéressant et
vous proposez même des des circuits des
balades à faire alors justement ce que
j'ai découvert c'est que il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui proposaient des
circuits mais que pour arriver à un
circuit c'était compliqué sur internet
donc j'ai regroupé tous les circuits qui
sont proposés par l'Office de Tourisme
par exemple par par d'autres j'ai
regroupé tout ca sur un seul site et
donc les gens peuvent choisir ils
choisissent en fonction d'un thème je
veux faire un tour dans la forêt je veux
faire un tour dans la ville je veux un
circuit botanique un circuit
gastronomique et donc et plus des
circuits que moi j'ai inventé par
moi-même de par mes mes visites visite
dans la forêt dans la ville alors il y a
combien de circuits environ au total
aujourd'hui on est on est à plus de 50
circuits plus de 50 circuit oui oui et
donc sur chaque circuit vous avez la
longueur la durée la difficulté et puis
un petit résumé du du circuit voilà il y
a aussi une partie sur le shopping la
culture le sport en fait c'est un peu
l'art de
vivre absolument oui c'est l'art de
vivre j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
Roger gickel alors Roger jquel c'est pas
le journaliste auquel beaucoup pensent
mais c'est un un grand sportif de de
Saint-Germain en lait qui a porté la
flamme olympique en 1968 et alors quand
on rencontre une personne comme ça il
vous parle de Saint-Germain du sport
de il est intarissable voilà et donc au
final ce livre peut s'apparenter à un
guide de de Saint-Germain ouais alors
ouais justement c'est ça un peu la
difficulté c'est pas vraiment un guide
c'est pas vraiment un livre culturel
c'est quelque chose de nouveau c'est
quelque chose qui je pense va être va se
développer dans d'autres villes j'ai
cherché pour voir si des choses
semblables avaient été faites
apparemment pas et cette idée justement
de QR code de photos mélanger avec des
dessins il y a énormément de dessins
aussi dans le livre pourquoi avoir
ajouté des dessins ah parce je voulais
pas faire un album photo d'accord VO je
quand on aujourd'hui quand vous
consultez des guides soit c'est des
guides fait pas cher et donc pas pas
très joli soit c'est des guides un peu
plus chers et puis mais on croit
vraiment se balader dans un album photo
là je pense que le dessin il attire
l'attention de la personne qui lit sur
l'architecture sur un
trait et ce mélange de dessins et et de
photos fait que le la personne prend son
temps et ne tourne pas les pages comme
on tourne les pages d'un album photo et
c'est aussi un livre 100 % bilingue
alors c'est un livre qui est 100 %
bilingue B moimême je je parle anglais
mais pour être vraiment clair j'ai
repris tout le livre en anglais avec une
une personne qui est irlandaise et la
règle c'était la suivante je ne voulais
pas de traduction c'est-à-dire que je
disais vous regardez cette image et vous
me dites sur à quoi vous pensez
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous inspire et alors
et et donc c'était génial parce qu'on a
eu des échanges extraordinaires elle
mais parfois entre la version française
et la version anglaise c'est deux sujets
complètement différents mais c'est ça
qui est intéressant à Saint-Germain on a
quand même 15 % de la population qui est
de langue anglaise ou en tout cas pas de
langue française
d'origine donc pour eux ça ça sera
vraiment intéressant c'est aussi pour
les touristes qui vont venir peut-être
pour les Jeux Olympiques de Paris 2024
alors vous savez que Saint-Germain est
retenu pour accueillir la délégation
anglaise effectivement C claire moi je
suis en en en en relation avec
l'organisation en Angleterre qui
s'occupe des Jeux Olympiques et
notamment de l'équipe qui va venir à
SaintGermain et donc on est en train de
discuter pour le envoyer des livres pour
permettre aux gens qui vont venir de
d'avoir un support en anglais alors
est-ce que vous avez des anecdotes sur
la ville de de Saint-Germain la des des
choses que les gens ne connaissent pas
forcément ah je fais vous en raconter
une parce que là ce jour-là on était
vraiment surpris euh c'est quand nous
avons visiter l'Hôtel de noail alors
l'hôtel de noil c'est l'un des plus
anciens des plus célèbres de de de
Saint-Germain et c'est un hôtel qui se
visite il y pas beaucoup qui se visite
mais celui-là se visite on a passé une
bonne demi-journée avec eux et notre
hôte nous a servi des chocolats des
petits chocolats qui avaient été
fabriqués avec des légumes et avec des
fruits comme on le faisait du temps de
Louis XIV et donc c'était la même
recette qui qu'elle avait utilisé et à
l'époque dans le dans le parc du de
l'hôtel de Noy il y avait des serres
avec on cultiver toutes sortes des
ananas et cetera et donc elle nous avait
préparé ces petits chocolats c'était
assz assez génial et si vous deviez
donner une bonne raison aux
téléspectateurs d'acheter votre livre ce
serait laquelle alors j'ai voulu faire
quelque chose de beau vous savez euh
euh Maurice Denis euh les les nabiis
aimait ce qui était simple et beau et
j'ai un peu adopté cette philosophie
faire quelque chose de simple mais de
très beau et ce livre je pense qu'on
peut le laisser traîner sur une table à
salon et puis le soir on tourne quelques
page et puis ça donne envie le weekend
d'aller faire une balade dans dans un
coin de découvrir quelque chose de
nouveau Maurice deni qui a maintenant
son musée enfin la demeure de Maurice
Denis qui est devenue le musée
départemental à Saint-Germain ENL dont
je fais partie des amis de Maurice Denis
qui soutiennent les peintures de Maurice
Denis et bien merci beaucoup PhIP
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
plateau alors votre livre on peut le
retrouver fin novembre en librairie
alors fin novembre en librairie et il
commence à sortir en ce moment un peu
partout voilà merci beaucoup merci merci
à vous c'est la fin de ce numéro div
livre à bientôt sur
tv78